hi everyone it's Jerry I have an
instructive game to share with you from
the 1997 lenar tournament on the white
end Alexis shirov playing against Gary
Kasparov so let's see this light Square
strategy in action by casprov really an
excellent game ahead out of this opened
Sicilian
nidorf Bishop E3 white aims for the
English attack
Far and Away most popular from this
position
E5 Knight
B3 Bishop E6 and
F3 F3 controls the G4 Square no knight
jump there to bother the bishop in this
game
Kasparov jumps at the opportunity to
bother the bishop before F3 is in this
is noted as the anti-land English attack
the reply Bishop
G5 the bishop can of course go back home
and this Knight can return to its
favorite Square we could repeat moves
and have a quick three-fold repetition
draw should white play in this way well
that would be a crime against chess or
at least that's what Mikel tall
thought no worries of a quick draw with
these two Dynamic players on board we
are in for a fight Bishop G5 it is some
tempy gained against the dark Square
bishop and in the process space for
casprov on the king's side with that
space comes some weaknesses H5 is a hole
F5 is a bit more
weakened Bishop
G7 the reply now Bishop
E2
considered better is H3 H3 will scare
the Knight away Bishop E2 not so much
the reply is H5 a move that is both
defensive and
aggressive in what way is it
aggressive well if white tries H3 one
move later there is
H4 this move Now tracks the dark Square
Bishop
the Knight covers its Retreat
Square so in this game it is Bishop
takes Knight by the way something I
noted with this game this is the first
case where when one of CAS brov's minor
pieces is attacked it doesn't move it's
almost like time and time again he just
refuses to react to his opponent's
threats simply secures the Knight
right now Bishop takes Knight Bishop
takes Bishop this is the imbalance we
play with light Square Bishop versus
knight currently things are cool for
white with the structure and Bishop
pawns light Bishop dark
great what will be a good strategy for
black in general playing with this
unopposed light Square Bishop well try
and create holes on the light squares in
White's camp the more holes you can
create on light
squares that's going to be good news for
the light Square Bishop its eyes will
widen its prospects will
improve all right we continue with
castles Knight
C6 where else is that Knight going to go
there's a problem now on D4 white must
tend to that note certain moves that
aren't played in this position H4 may be
tempting
G4 as well Knight C6 we can say retains
the flexibility with these pawns maybe
H4 maybe G4 keep white
guessing all right the reply is Bishop
F2 if white tries to take advantage of
one of the gaps on Black's King side for
instance Knight
F5 black can swipe the Knight and then
land a check on B6 and say thank you for
the B
Pawn Bishop
F2 not only covers the Knight but covers
that Queen B6
idea at the same time white has released
the pressure on
D6 and this allows
E6 E6 covers the Knight F5 jump couple
new squares available for the queen as
well D6 is a downside D6 is currently
unprotected Ed but at the moment not
accessible the reply now is Knight C to
E2 if white exchanges a pair of knights
here black is recapturing with the
bishop making sure D6 is
defended and if white continued with
Bishop D4 a good reply would be Bishop
E5 saying I I'm okay taking on isolated
Center pawns because I would have some
Square to Pivot two on
D4 all right in this game Knight C to
E2 casprov now says I know what you're
up
to you want to exchange a pair of
knights and after I recapture you're
going to go from rank two to rank
four I don't want you to have such an
easy time with that so let's avoid the
Knight exchange white does have a lot of
pieces competing for that one square
maybe a good idea for white to get rid
of one of those pieces so there isn't
that great of a competition going on
over
D4 the knight from E5 has an eye on
maybe C4 white rules that one out with
B3 also supports a C4
Advance the computer isn't a big fan of
B3 it likes C3 as a uh C prefers C3 over
B3
if later Knight C4 you could then give
it a kick there's a bit of an issue with
B3 I wonder if you can spot what that
is uh can you spot Cas bra's next move
feel free to pause the
video okay now I must admit when I see
B3 one of the first things that comes to
mind for me is this weakness on C3 is
there something I could maybe do along
this diagonal is there a way to take
advantage of of a pin
maybe there
isn't uh this is an
unusual situation we have here the
downside with B3 is only revealed after
a couple pawn
moves the best move in this position
move played G4 this is the beginning of
black breaking down White's pawns that
are on light squares with every white
Pawn that's on a light Square
well whenever you can make one of
White's pawns that's on a light Square
move you're creating a light Square
weakness the reply is F4 there we go
there's now a weakness on e4 E4 is a
ho what is the reply now one more pop
quiz what would you play
here okay well the Knight is attacked
but as mentioned earlier there seems to
be this pattern where when a minor piece
is is attacked doesn't
move instead he continues to push his
pawns H4 on board so now there's maybe
H3 or even G3 which would ensure some
file is cracked open if it hits with a
fork even if it costs a pawn what is
going on here though if the Knight is
captured in the game it's Bishop
E3 if the Knight is captured black takes
with the pawn
now when you do a quick glance of this
position you might say oh this this is a
fourth ranked Knight right in the center
has a lot of options well guess what
when you play B3 you've taken away one
of the few remaining options from that
Knight it has no moves this would be
casprov way to get that piece back and
in general he he's probably the one who
is benefiting with more Pawn exchanges
more open diag more open files this is
going to be good news for the side with
the bishop
pair so white doesn't go for this
sequence instead Bishop E3 gets out of
the G3 move um with the fork cracking
open the king uh King side
there still doesn't have to move the
knight in comes H3 now continuing to
break down the light squares in White's
Camp white can
definitely uh well white cannot afford
to make a capture on H3 this would
activate the Rook be the best piece in
the
game G3 in this game so there is a hole
on
G2
F3 E4 big problems for white the
computer is going to say right around
here it's still equal is but things that
are tipping in Black's favor long
term King safety is a problem for white
black is already thinking about somehow
getting this queen right here G2 for
me there's no direct variation into that
square but in general the more the
position opens up the more accessible
the white king will be more vulnerable
it will
be all right from here Knight
C6 you could also Castle because the
same situation here you would get the
piece back after the pawn recaptures but
he goes back to
C6 Queen D3
castles and from here it is Rook a to
D1 if white tries to break with
F5 in this position black can take and
the Knight is not in a spot to recapture
because there there's a capture and then
this Rook would fall
so Rook a to
D1 this may now be an idea now that
there is no longer a pin but black is
there first he continues to chip away at
the light squares he's now
controlling another hole in White's camp
with a pawn all of these squares under
Black's
control where to go from here it is
C4 Queen A5 you know for many moves in
this game I was wondering to myself why
isn't he playing Rook to C8 it seemed
like a reasonable move going to a half
openen file he has a different idea in
mind with this rook in this game also in
many cases uh maybe this Rook move was
delayed because queenside castles might
have been an option he wanted to go
forward with now that these kingside
pawns are all the way up here
retaining some options by not moving
that Queen Rook Queen A5 in this game
Knight C3 Rook a to E8 and with this
move the Rook will find activity on the
E file one way or the
other certainly if white continues here
with a capture on F5 we take with the E
Pawn and we say thank you for opening up
the E
file what if white plays a move like
Rook F to E1 move played in the game
here's the other detail in comes E5
creating more tension the E file is
going to crack open by force there is a
fork
here this is good news again for the
side with the safer King again black has
dreams of getting the queen to G2
somehow or
another the reaction Knight takes on C6
something you can't do something you
should definitely ly not do is take on
E5 and invite this Knight into E5 with
Tempo and then eyeing up the F3 Square
no
way in this game it's Knight takes C6
Bishop takes
C6 and now
B4 okay the reply to this is Queen to
A3 this is considered the best the very
best move why is this Pawn not picked up
well black is avoiding Knight D5 with
Tempo you certainly wouldn't want to
take the Knight here and invite the
queen in with
check if the queen goes here or here
there's this as a capture it still
prefers black but uh this here is the
very best Queen A3 doesn't give white an
opportunity to advance a piece with
Tempo there's a pin on the the Knight as
well the reply in this game is B5 if the
Knight tries to go into D5 here black
can exchange queens and then break down
the center taking on F4 taking on e4
next all right in this game it is
B5 F takes excuse me e takes F4 first
opens up this pressure on C3
Bishop takes F4 AB CB and a nice check
thrown in
here Queen C5 right
away this demotes the bishop it's no
longer observing D6 and The Rook is no
longer securing
E4 only after demoting the bishop does
black take on C3
Pawn takes Bishop getting the piece back
Queen takes on
C6 Queen takes
D6 Queen takes E4 possible because the
bishop is on E3 not F4 and finally black
is in a spot coordinating with the most
advanced
Pawn H3 we have a maid on
G2 white has to get the Queens off and
does Queen D5 but white is down the pawn
queen takes Queen Rook takes Queen and
nice followup here Bishop C3 there is a
bit of a pin
here the bishop still has a couple
moves where it will secure The Rook by
but by flicking in Bishop
C3 it pulls The Rook to E2 and now this
guy has no moves because the Rook would
simply fall so only after creating this
inconvenience do we have the doubling on
the E file and there's no good way to
get out of this pin what is tried Rook
D3 note where the bishop Retreats
here Bishop F6 doesn't go back
to a secure square a square where the
king is defending the
bishop there's a detail here I want you
to take note of the difference between
Bishop G7 and Bishop F6 I'll be
highlighting this very soon the reply
now is Rook on
D or Rook on E to
D2 one final move in this
position I wonder if you can spot it
feel free to pause the
video okay here it is Rook takes Bishop
and white
resigns
now first of all if white gets off of
this file by going to
C2 here is how black can continue you
could take the bishop and then play
Bishop to D4 with this
pin and if this Rook goes here this is a
forever pin an eternal pin you cannot
get out of it black would have all day
to put the here play F5 capture a couple
times and then this will be attacked
three times and it's only defended
twice that's one of many ways to
continue in this exact
position why does white in this game
play to this Square well it's to
cover this bishop D4
followup the down side of going to D2
here is this detail after Rook takes
Bishop if the game continued from here
it would follow Rook takes
Rook Rook takes rook and no in this
position because the bishop is on
F6 not G7 white doesn't have this check
first and only then the
capture King takes Rook Bishop G5 would
land here this is how black gets the
piece back and in the end in this
simplified
ending we're able to push through up the
pawn in comes F4 G takes F4 in comes G3
H takes G3 Pawn quality black wins a
step away from
queening this one goes no further though
after Rook takes Bishop on E3 shirov
resigns so interesting how this one
played out in the
opening in the middle game kasparov's
play was on the light squares and in
this ending there ended up being a
tactic on the dark squares of all
squares interesting how that
happens what are your
thoughts anyhow Feel Free as usual to
leave any feedback to this video in the
comments below I hope you enjoyed it and
maybe took a thing or two away that's
all for now take care
bye